iron 75 % des québécois pensent que
l'entrepreneuriat est un bon choix de
carrière selon le dernier rapport du
globo entrepreneurship monitor
cela dit selon statistique canada il y a
moins une entreprise par habitant au
québec qu'ailleurs au pays
serge bochum est avec nous ce soir
entrepreneur bonsoir bonsoir
entrepreneurs et porte parole d'expo
entrepreneurs qui revient pour une
troisième édition demain et après demain
qu'est ce que c'est d'abord cet
événement ben c'est un salon typiquement
entreprenariale dans sa danse a tenu
puisque vous savez la plupart des salons
des expositions un format traditionnel
ou habituels les ailes et les kiosques
et les exposants ici expo entrepreneur
c'est conçu par un jeune entrepreneur
créatif qui s'est inspiré de nouveaux
modèles peu partout sur la planète pour
créer un espace qui favorise les
rencontres donc c'est pas le
traditionnel discipline
l'affichage par aller mais c'est tous
des ondes et tout est organisé pour
livrer la promesse du salon qui ne le
rend qu'on peut tout changer
donc tout est organisé pour que les gens
puissent se rencontrer autant les
intervenants les ressources des
exposants qu'évidemment les participants
et donc les gens qui sont exposés
quelque sorte je voyais que j'avais
beaucoup de et merci des grappes
industrielles des aubes régionaux qui
veulent attirer des entrepreneurs chez
eux dans les différentes régions du
québec tout à fait en fait il ya de
l'ensemble de l'écosystème et présente
donc sa vie qu'il ya au québec environ
série peut-être pas mais près de 1000
organismes qui tente d'aider à leur
façon l'entrepreneuriat steevy lille la
couche entrepreneuriat québécoise et 120
de ces organismes et l'eau seront
présents 120 des plus importants
évidemment la de ses mille dangers des
cités et chacun va tenter de à sa façon
évidemment d'aider les entrepreneurs à à
s'épanouir à s'établir mais aussi
évidemment d'attirer certaine ces
investissements là en terme de
créativité en terme de matière grise
dans sa région pour revitaliser
évidemment le tissu économique des
régions
vous êtes entrepreneur on vous a connu
au dragon particulièrement durant
plusieurs années
comment vont entrepreneuriat selon-vous
selon votre vision des choses en ce
moment au québec
je dirais qu'il va drôlement bien dans
la dimension où il ya beaucoup absolue
en disant deux triplés l'intention
d'entreprendre et on attribue également
les démarches entreprendre des québécois
et québécoises ont que c'est juste une
excellente nouvelle
clinton
2009 à 2019 ou à peu près la raison on
est littéralement passé de 7 % de la
population qui avait l'intention
d'entreprendre un jour à 21%
la population qui avait avait
l'intention d'entreprendre alors ça
c'est une très bonne nouvelle discute
encore une très grande nouvelle c'est
que cela même le facteur de croissance
encore plus important chez les jeunes en
boîte 35
donc on a vraiment libérés littéralement
explosé l'intention je dirais de la
jeune population comme vous le
d'exporter bajeux l'expliquent par
différents facteurs je vais en prendre
un peu un crédit mais évidemment
l'émission radio canada des dragons
popularisé à démocratiser aussi le
langage des affaires donc les gens
commencent à s'habituer
les actions des parts des
investissements des projets de démarrage
à démystifier aussi satisfait ce monde
cet hiver un peu peu complexe que c'est
que partir en business et d'autres dont
un concept qui ont soutenu aussi ces
initiatives mais mais je pense que
justement la présence de d'une émission
forte comme ça ou qu'avec avec qui ont
encore à 7 800 milles de cap'découverte
être même plus davantage dans certaines
situations vous savez c'est près du
quart de la population active au travail
tu vu ça mille personnes on parle de 4.5
millions je pense au québec qui
travaille donc c'est pas mal de monde
qui regarde un show qui ultimement ce
favorise plus la multiplication des
initiatives pour stimuler une
entrepreneure je pense que tous ensemble
a donné un boom intéressant d'art je
dirais donc terroir dont le planter un
paquet dirait maintenant voulait
récolter ce le dit est ce que le québec
est en retard par rapport aux autres
provinces parce que quand on regarde les
statistiques par 1000 habitants le
québec est en bas on est de 10% je pense
le rapport à 13 14 % dans les autres
propres et le maintenant c'est le grand
défi que le provins que la province doit
relever c'est celui de passer de
l'intention du démarrage ou du
démarchage à entreprendre et à faire
évidemment croire ces entreprises et ce
passage où et pas nécessairement facile
parce que si on a entre guillemets ex
crise tous ces gens tous ces jeunes tous
ces gens à démarrer des entreprises
mettant tous les outils à
alignement le faire à concrétiser ces
plans là et ça c'est un travail un peu
plus difficile parce que la prise de
risque
c'est l'ensemble du projet vous savez
parfois le côté négatif je dirais la
popularité de l'entrepreneuriat c'est de
rendre sa simple et accessible les gens
pensent que ça il suffit d'une bonne
idée pour se lancer en affaires
malheureusement il suffit pas que c'est
une bonne idée mais beaucoup plus
d'exécutions de regrouper les gens de
mettre les bonnes personnes au bon
endroit
le timing d'un paquet d'éléments de fond
qui est que cette entreprise là va
pouvoir voir le jour et ça ces éléments
le sont moins bien connues ou comprises
de la population est ce que c'est pas le
revers de la médaille des dragons
justement d'avoir rendu ce trek ou
d'entreprendre et finalement de se
rendre compte que c'est pas mal plus
compliqué que tout simplement avoir une
bonne idée puis de dire je m'aime moi je
dirais que c'est le revers ou c'est une
condition essentielle au succès dont on
ne parle pas l'émission je pense qu'ils
devraient peut-être avoir d'autres
émissions qui d'autres émissions ou
d'autres initiatives publiques qui
pourraient peut-être démystifier ces
autres étapes du succès du développement
ou de démarrage d'une entreprise qu'est
ce que vous faites ces jours ci c'est
moche mais j'en fais pas mal ouais je
m'épuise beaucoup justement à stimuler
l'entrepreneuriat au québec donc je
travaille entre autres expos
entrepreneur un salon qui qui se déroule
présentement du mois qui commence dès
demain à place bonaventure on attend
plus de 6000 personnes
3ème édition je suis porte parole de
l'événement et animateur sur les lieux
demain et 2
jeudi également je m'implique aussi dans
toutes ses initiatives entrepreneuriales
dans le réseau des femmes d'affaires du
québec je suis membre du conseil
d'administration d'abb à l'association
des clubs étudiés entrepreneurs du
québec du parcours entrepreneurial rémi
marcoux la grande journée l'épisode
entrepreneurs bref je donne beaucoup de
mon temps la cause entrepreneuriale au
québec qui vous passionne et qui me
passionne et je pense est important pour
les québécois et québécoises parce qu'en
fait je crois que l'amélioration des
l'entrepreneuriat au québec a des
conséquences directes sur l'économie et
du coup ces conditions de vie au québec
serge beauchemin merci beaucoup avait
gardé et merci bien